في الوقت الذي حقق فيه طالبان الأفغان مكاسب ،
فإن حركة طالبان الباكستانية
تشجعت في أول مقابلة تلفزيونية له على الإطلاق ،
يجيب زعيمهم نور والي مسعود على الأسئلة التي
أرسلها إليه سي إن إن عبر
وسطاء في مكان غير معروف بالقرب من الحدود
الباكستانية الأفغانية.  انتصار طالبان هو انتصار لمسلمين كاملين.
علاقاتنا مبنية على التعاطف الأخوي
والمبادئ الإسلامية
قتل أسلاف مسعود الثلاثة
جميعًا بضرباتنا بطائرات بدون طيار للقتال جنبًا إلى جنب مع
طالبان الأفغانية التي
استهدفتنا قواتنا ، ويشمل سجلها الدموي
هجوم 2009
الذي أودى بحياة تسعة أشخاص بينهم سبعة.
ضباط ومقاولون في قاعدة عسكرية
قريبة من الحدود
الباكستانية ومذبحة 145 شخصًا
معظمهم من الأطفال في مدرسة باكستانية في عام
2014.
وأصبح مسعود زعيمًا في عام 2018
وصنفته الأمم المتحدة لاحقًا بأنه
إرهابي عالمي وأضفته إلى قائمة العقوبات بسببه.
صلاته بالقاعدة
اليوم ينفي تلك الصلات بالقاعدة
وهذا مرحباً  لا تزال مجموعة s تقاتل
إلى جانب طالبان الأفغانية
قتالنا في باكستان فقط ونحن
في حالة حرب مع قوات الأمن الباكستانية
، ونأمل بشدة في السيطرة
على المناطق الحدودية القبلية الباكستانية
وجعلها مستقلة ولكن بينما
خاض الجيش الباكستاني عقودًا من الزمن  -
مقاومة التمرد الطويلة ضد حزب ttp
في المخابرات الباكستانية الباكستانية
، دعمت ISI والجيش حركة طالبان الأفغانية
على الرغم من أنهم ينفون ذلك الآن حيث أن
طالبان الأفغانية تكسب
رد فعل لباكستان تلوح في الأفق الخطر بالنسبة
لباكستان
هو أن طالبان أفغاني أقوى
يمكنه ذلك.  في الواقع ، يقلل من تعاونه
مع ISI
في السيطرة على ttp وهذا هو
الذي يمكّن TPT
يطالب TP بالفعل بقانون الشريعة الذي
يحد من
تعليم الفتيات ويرغبن في
تطبيق
الشريعة في باكستان وأراضي باكستان
بالفعل هناك الكثير من الخوف على
العقدين
الماضيين كانت العلاقات بين الولايات المتحدة وباكستان معقدة
بسبب
المسار المزدوج المزعوم لباكستان  نهج الدعم بالنسبة
لنا
أثناء دعم طالبان الأفغاني سرًا ،
إنه توازن دقيق مكاسب طالبان الأفغانية
تهدد
حزب ttp الذي يعتمد الآن على
انتصار طالبان
الأفغاني وهم واثقون من
أنهم سيكونون قادرين على مواصلة
قتالهم ضد باكستان
في حالة  طالبان يتولى
زمام الأمور في
أفغانستان ، باكستان التي ستكون في حالة
ألم أكبر مما هي عليه في أفغانستان ، حيث
ستتعرض للتهديد أكثر بكثير من
موقعه غير المعلن ،
يشير مسعود كوي إلى المكاسب
التي يمكن أن تأتي في طريقه
وفقًا لتعاليم انتصار الإسلام لمسلم
واحد
مفيد بالضرورة لمسلم آخر ،
لكن كيف
سيثبت انتصار طالبان الأفغانية أنه مفيد
لوقت طالبان الباكستاني سيخبرنا
في هذه الأثناء على الرغم من نفيه
توقعه
أن مقاتلي مسعود سيستمرون في دعم
طالبان الأفغانية
نيك روبرتسون سي إن لندن.